How is that food coming along, Mr. Pearson?
It's coming, it's coming.
Hey, Orth.
Hope you choke on it.
No worries about it.
I got you another grand.
Oh, you're awake.
You just woke up, aren't you?
I I have syndrome.
What kind of syndrome?
I don't know.
There's nothing wrong withy you!
Has a thing.
钟
Hello.
Don't forget, lift with your knees.
Good work, Mr. Morgan.
Come on, I'm so hungry.
Get into where we need supplies for an army.
There must be enough for me to have a couple of bites.
Come on.
Thank you.
How are you?
Laundry and sewing.
The exciting life of an outlaw.
Yes, if they only knew
how boring...
How boring it really is.
Is anybody getting me some?
Hello, travel cop.
Hello.
Thank you.